Transcription: Cécilia Canal
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Promis,
je vais y aller tranquille,
Je vais pas vous poser un gros
sprint dès le départ,
donc on va y aller tranquillement.
Si je vous dis que je livre des repas,
mais aussi des récipients
en verre réutilisables
ainsi que des pièces automobiles,
tout ça évidemment à vélo,
vous l’aurez compris,
en étant à la fois salarié, mais aussi
le propriétaire de la plateforme
pour laquelle je travaille.
Ça fait beaucoup, et peut être que
vous n’allez pas me croire,
et pourtant, tout ceci est bien vrai.
D’ailleurs, ce matin, en arrivant au local
de notre jeune coopérative,
j’ai choisi de prendre
notre plus gros vélo cargo,
à assistance électrique bien sûr,
pour aller livrer
des dizaines de kilos de nourriture
préparée par un restaurateur partenaire
dans des récipients en verre
réutilisables.
Je pars avec mon vélo, je vais
les livrer cinq kilomètres plus loin,
dans une salle d’escalade.
Arrivé là bas, je décharge,
puis ensuite, je récupère les récipients
utilisés par la salle pour les ramener
à la base.
Arrivé à la base de notre partenaire
qui gère la consigne et le lavage,
je récupère des récipients propres
pour les emmener ensuite
chez un autre restaurateur
qui lui, à son tour,
préparera la prochaine tournée.
Évidemment, je vais à 100 à l’heure
et le midi arrive très vite.
Vient l’heure de livrer les repas
pour plus d’une vingtaine de restaurants.
Donc moi j’enfile mon sac à dos,
j’enfourche mon vélo de route
et c’est parti.
On est affranchis des grandes plateformes
que vous connaissez habituellement.
Ce qui différencie des autres,
c’est que nous, nous sommes déjà salariés,
on a un matériel professionnel et en plus,
on bénéficie d’une véritable formation.
Plus tard, dans l’après-midi,
toujours à vélo,
je reviens au local et cette fois-ci,
je choisis un autre vélo cargo,
un peu moins gros cette fois-ci,
et je pars en périphérie de la ville.
Arrivé là bas, on me confie des pièces
automobiles que je dois livrer en urgence
en centre ville.
Vous comprendrez qu’à 16 h,
l’heure de pointe,
le trafic et les bouchons, et parfois
l’agressivité de certains conducteurs
me rendent la tâche un peu compliquée.
Mais finalement, j’arrive à l’heure,
calme et serein auprès des garagistes.
Une belle illustration
de la complémentarité entre
les transports motorisés et le vélo.
Ce qu’a d’ailleurs bien compris
notre partenaire
qui, lui, gère une centaine
d’expéditions en France
avec des camions,
mais qui nous fait confiance
pour les livrer efficacement
sur le dernier kilomètre,
ou plutôt les derniers kilomètres.
Finalement, je suis là devant vous
ce soir, après toutes ces tournées,
pour vous parler de possibilité
d’une économie
basée autour de transports adaptés.
Évidemment, le vélo ne remplacera pas
tous les transports motorisés
que vous connaissez.
Mais nous, nous nous efforçons chaque jour
de démontrer qu’il est possible
de proposer une alternative
à ce que vous connaissez déjà
et aux utilisations de la voiture
qu’on a l’habitude de faire,
voire même, des camions.
À la fin de ma journée,
avec les collègues,
on a le sentiment
d’avoir impacté positivement la planète
avec notre action,
évidemment à notre échelle.
Finalement, je dirais qu’on a
une action qui a un sens
et surtout qui va dans le bon sens.
J’espère personnellement que d’ici à 2030,
la cyclo logistique,
comme on peut l’appeler,
va se développer
en centre ville, mais aussi
dans les périphéries et pourquoi pas
le développer dans nos campagnes.
Je vous remercie de m’avoir écouté.
(Applaudissements)